i don't i don't eat chocolate but this
is more chocolate than i've had
so this is uh i remember how we were
debating if we were gonna have dinner
after filming this episode
we are not having that dinner after phil
so i just enjoyed the atmosphere of
having a dinner together this is
dinner with the boys you literally just
witnessed three people have dinner
together
um two hours yeah for two weeks a
literal combini dinner
what would you say is your favorite i
guess item from each
genre of food so you're saving the hot
foods first yeah so hot foods which one
which one raised the cream in the hot
okay hot food i'm i'm still standing
seven
seven if you want to find chicken lesson
fried chicken man seven fried chicken
seven beef bowl seven any hot foods
honestly i think i think lawson have
been doing the hot food better man
it'll be gonna be real with you man if
i'm gonna be the mediator i would have
to
just give it to the seven you [ __ ]
for real
yes yes i'd have to just give him a
second the whole
again i don't eat the fried food so i
don't [ __ ] care
all we know is that family my friends
sucks ass i never get the fried food
from the company because i'm just like
if i'm gonna if i'm gonna have fried
food i'm gonna go to a [ __ ]
restaurant yeah if i'm gonna [ __ ] up my
body i'm gonna do it in a good place
yeah yeah you know what i mean
hey good money yeah i want the best [ __ ]
if this is like my cheat day right yeah
um what about the best like sandwiches
then oh
sandwich probably lawson's have i
converted you into seeing the way of the
tuna sandwich
i mean look the tuna the tuna sandwich
is lawson is definitely better but the
egg sandwich family mods better
if only they could join four yeah yeah i
would agree if only they could join
forces
like runny egg sandwiches should never
be a thing it's not ronnie
it it i don't
like egg paste shouldn't be a thing it's
not paste it's just it's mashed down
i wanna like i wanna taste the eggs i
want the texture
i don't need it i don't need it i need
it like even i prefer it
even even scrambled egg has a texture
this was like scrambled egg that was put
into a paste
it is it is i like it it's like egg
flavored glue
me like they're both very strong
but to me the tuners are so much better
the tuner is hands down better
it's like why would i want it and also
uh like
there's supermarkets that like aren't
any of those that get like the
sandwiches as well and the tuna always
tastes like the family mart one for some
reason yeah yeah for some reason
i feel the awesome one they actually
took like the canned tuna yeah it's good
[ __ ] yeah good [ __ ] chips
i feel like the lawson's one the tuna
sandwiches is better definitely better
the egg sandwiches
family mart will definitely better i
don't eat that many sandwiches from the
combinies
so i don't really have too much of a
strong opinion what about the
uh what about the uh onigiri the rice
balls lawsons lawsons
yeah hands down lawson's hands down the
sample size of one type
i did not realize though that because we
we saw two
seven on the yuri's i don't know if one
will not will make it to the final cut
but we opened up two
they both looked as depressing as each
other my god
they're pretty sad the awesome one was
clean it was nicely
yeah and the fillings were in every
single bite like that's
no matter where i buy i need to get a
bit of filling yeah absolutely
on the market lost lawson's definitely
by far the best on a year thank you guys
thank you
appreciate it uh what about the what
else do we cover i guess
snacks like we had like the like fish
snacks meat snacks
i mean the fish snacks and meat snacks i
think we can all agree are all pretty
mid
yeah they're all they're all like the
same level they're all oh no i like the
fish crisps
the lawson fish crips yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah i think that the the way that
lawsons do the squid as well is really
funny
yeah yeah we unfortunately didn't get to
try any like dried squid or white fish
or something but
like it's it's something that a lot of
people from
you know america and england that i've
met have because i bring this [ __ ] from
thailand
to england and people like why are you
eating fish food
it kind of does smell a bit like a
little bit yeah it does but it tastes
[ __ ] awesome it's the perfect amount
of salty it's perfect to go with your
beer
absolutely uh fish snacks just and you
can't like you you don't know the full
enjoyment of fish snacks until you've
had a cold beer with them
yeah you have a beer with them i don't
know and i must say i'm thoroughly
impressed with the one cop personally
i thought i was what going finished it i
i'm impressed i'm impressed i thought it
was gonna taste like [ __ ] and it tasted
not great but drinkable way better than
chris
i would i would buy another one of those
what the [ __ ] did chris just bring us
like
just like the sponges the worst one he
could find he's just like pissed in a
bottle he's like yeah
trust me he's so potent he has an
alcohol
um my favorite snack i think it's got to
be the kitkat
watermelon yeah
above the rest and then obviously all
the breads disappointed me
yeah the breads were kind of made this
thought no no no no
no no no it's not let me let me just
choco babies
get the [ __ ] out of here yeah and again
like you know like the ramen and stuff
like that the chocolate baby the stuff
that i grew up with this shit's great
oh you're having another existential
crisis right now
[ __ ] i i took a bite and i was just like
this tastes awful and i'm just like no
this tastes good
you gotta [ __ ] try this please try
this
you don't have to okay no i i got it the
initial taste tastes [ __ ] awful
all right and then the aftertaste kicks
in and i'm like this tastes like uh
what is this the aftertaste gives me the
same kind of taste i
when when you're cooking like a brownie
or something and you have like cooking
chocolate
and you took you're cooking like a
chocolate pudding and then as a kid you
kind of just like
have a bit of the chocolate you know you
see it doesn't scoop a bit into your
mouth
i'm not gonna lie i wasn't listening i
was just enjoying connor looking dead
over there
it doesn't taste like that you're
chatting [ __ ] but
all in all i'd have to say you can get
like this you're a woman you're a winner
if you're in japan this is not even
all about this is not even a corner of
what you can get at a combini
[ __ ] the best tasting thing what was the
worst tasting thing oh god
okay because i'm having a hard time
deciding between this
and this oh no honestly the crab cake
the crab cake oh the crab cake was crap
no actually
it's it's this for me this is this has
the worst
aftertaste in the crab cake i still have
the aftertaste of this in my mouth right
now
after eating all that [ __ ] was gross
yeah chica i mean
i i grew up i grew up with chico and
there's a reason why i stopped eating it
because it's
it literally smells like vomit yeah it
ain't really oh that was probably the
worst flavored one was the worst thing
but yeah again like this is nowhere near
the variety that you can get at a
convenience store right like
there's so many more snacks i mean you
know i haven't even talked about the
fact that you know you can buy
basically [ __ ] anything at a
convenience store pay your utility bills
you can
pay your rent yeah you can send packages
you can send packages you can
yeah toiletries you can get you know
like lawson's next to me
has now basically just has a whole
section
for like household items it's like you
can buy like bed sheets
like soap containers yeah yeah yeah yeah
like yeah weird [ __ ] that you're like
why do i need this here it's like a mini
ikea
lawsons it's so strange but really cool
you can buy stuff like you can buy
technical stuff like sd cards
yeah yeah yeah like charges and stuff
like that yeah i bought
i bought underwear from uh i have a pair
of honestly the best pair of socks i've
bought in japan yeah
from lawson's i have gloves
like the hand gloves that i bought from
family mart and i still wear them to
this yeah right
yeah so super super community so like
definitely when you come to japan
whenever the world opens up
uh yeah let us know what your favorite
is yeah let us know what your favorite
is
yeah yeah it might be neither of our
right it could be it could be
stop it could be yamazaki who knows